[Aplausos]
muy buenas y bienvenidas al horrible
mundo real
bien vamos a comenzar argumentando
varias cosas con vanagloria y con cierto
aire burlesco de lo que es la de web que
es de lo que vengo yo aquí hablar el
futuro y evidentemente analizando un
poquito también el presente de lo que es
la recta oscura que es el mayor crimen
que se comete actualmente tenemos dos
maravillosas definiciones de lo que es
la web la fantástica la que vemos todos
los días a lo mejor en internet que es
ese maravilloso mundo mágico con esta
imagen horrible que yo tanto odio
maravilloso mundo mágico lleno de
contrabandistas sicarios pequeñas clases
de asesinos hackers
y evidentemente drogas o la definición
real la que nos gusta los ingenieros que
es cualquier tipo de contenido que no
puede ser indexado por ningún tipo de
buscador y que requiere de tecnología o
de programas evidentemente para poder
ser visualizado esto no significa que
vuestra página web al no aparecer en los
buscadores estela de web no
esto significa que sois unos malos
webmasters pero eso se puede cambiar
aquí dentro evidentemente vamos a hablar
sobre todo de esa zona que siempre está
a un minuto de la medianoche el comercio
ilegal porque el comercio legal es muy
bueno para todo lo que es la de webs
porque está muy oculto pero no es un
evidentemente una falacia creer que todo
el comercio ilegal todo el crimen ilegal
se comete dentro de la web y se puede
mostrar de una forma sencilla como
buscando en google
un buscador bastante poderoso
evidentemente primera página a comprar
esteroides europa porque esteroides
porque perfectamente se puede conseguir
cualquier derivado de cannabinoides
hachís marihuana
por las calles pero es muy difícil
encontrar ciclo pantanos que son
aquellas sustancias que modifican el
cuerpo de una persona esteroides
entonces bueno se busca la primera
página primera página unos murcianos muy
majos que evidentemente lo mandan a casa
y no pasaran celes evidentemente no lo
hagáis pero bueno con esto acabamos de
demostrar que no es necesario una web
para comprar cualquier tipo de producto
ilegal entonces por qué razón vamos a
usar una red sos cura para esto la red
sos cura nos proporciona cierto tipo de
anonimato pero ya no sólo un anonimato
de personas sino nosotros vamos a
meternos aquí y voy a explicar por qué
las tiendas son muy difíciles de
localizar para cierto tipo de
investigaciones y de investigadores
cuando nos metemos lo que vemos son este
tipo de tiendas una tienda ilegal con un
escaparate para poder entrar en este
tipo de tiendas requiere que compres una
cuenta comprar una cuenta se paga en
bitcoin las bitcoin evidentemente es una
moneda volátil totalmente de cristo'
moneda y cuesta una burrada
en dinero real lo que yo tengo en dinero
para comprar hamburguesas de un euro son
aproximadamente diez mil euros para
poder vender en una tienda ilegal y una
próximamente unos mil doscientos mil 200
euros dependiendo de la cuenta y
dependiendo de la tienda para poder
comprar lo que hace que sea muy difícil
que una persona de esta fe sesenta euros
de un producto porque no se va a
arriesgar a perder una cuenta de diez
mil euros para poder vender cierto tipo
de productos aquí y qué es lo que
tenemos aquí lo que tenemos aquí es una
tienda horrible y porque es una tienda
horrible porque os la estoy enseñando le
estoy enseñando entonces ya la conocéis
esto es aburrido esto es horrible si yo
quiero que mi tienda sea totalmente
invisible a cualquier tipo de
investigación ya sea de personas como yo
o policiales
no puedo enseñarle a ningún lado tiene
que ser totalmente oculta y eso se puede
hacer y se hace de una forma súper
sencilla vamos a poner un ejemplo
sampleos mola yo voy a crear aquí una
tienda les voy a dar la clave a todos
los de aquí evidentemente después de la
descripción que se me ha dado
doy bastante miedo y nadie se atreverá a
[ __ ] mi página web y difunde
por lo tanto entre los que estamos aquí
tenemos acceso a una tienda ilegal
y nadie más no sale en ningún buscador
jamás lo va a tener ningún investigador
por lo tanto la mayoría del crimen es
indetectable totalmente indetectable a
día de hoy porque porque si yo solo de
la contraseña vosotros vosotros nadie
más nunca va a enterarse y eso dificulta
muchísimo la labor de todas aquellas
personas que intentan proteger a
aquellos que no se pueden proteger pero
bueno vamos a hablar de las tiendas es
tan maravilloso una tienda con un
escaparate vale las tiendas no contienen
productos porque estas tiendas no se
arriesgan lo que contiene son pequeñas
micro tiendas de distintos
contrabandistas o mafiosos los cuales
vamos a hablar ahora cuando compramos
una cuenta básica unos mil doscientos
mil 230 euros vale una cuenta de estas
concretamente
vamos a escaparate con cuatro tiendas
las cuatro tiendas venden productos
ilegales y encima es un alarde de
inteligencia y originalidad porque como
podemos observar usan cierto tipo de
transporte de personas que no voy a
mencionar para transportar cierto tipo
de productos de un punto a a un punto b
sin ser detectados de esa forma es muy
sencillo pasar por ejemplo la droga o
armas sin ser detectados por ningún tipo
de investigador mi trabajo consiste en
pillar a estas personas y reportar las
antes de que cometen algún delito
extraño pero bueno vamos a hablar de
cómo se compra antes de pasar al futuro
nosotros pensamos que se puede comprar
aquí por cripto monedas bitcoin voy a
hacer un ejercicio de fe con vosotros y
vosotras yo tengo aquí 20 libras quién
es el que me lo cambia por 20 euros mi
moneda vale más pero aquí no porque aquí
no podéis cambiarlo por prácticamente
ningún bien o servicio y si no cambiáis
aquí 6 perdiendo un contrabandista no va
vender por bitcoin algo que sea muy caro
y algo que sea difícil de conseguir
porque porque no me voy a arriesgar a
perder dinero para eso van a usar cierto
tipo de mecánicas de blanqueo de dinero
como por ejemplo usar plataformas y
pasarelas de pago como paypal o casas de
apuestas pero bueno esto es maravilloso
porque podemos comprobar que aquí mi
generación lo que hacía prácticamente
era comprar drogas derivados de opiáceos
y evidentemente medicamentos con receta
médica porque eso de ir al médico pues
ya que estamos en medicina lo digo
tardó mucho en llegar tarde mucho en
contra mis cosas pues bueno ya que estoy
lo compro aquí
este comercio está muy extendido entre
mi generación los millennials pero yo
vengo a hablar de aquí de cara al futuro
de la generación que más esfuerzo ha
generado la generación z la última
generación de todas la cual se promulga
en el futuro como la generación que se
le prometió tener un trabajo digno un
trabajo bien remunerado y como
evidentemente buenas salidas pero cuando
te ves con 30 años sin poder pagar un
piso de alquiler sin poder prácticamente
comer y yo ofrezco
por 50 euros 500 euros en mano
es altamente probable que la gente lo
acepte
si luego lo acepta es porque a lo mejor
podéis ser pillados no os preocupéis
todo esto es anónimo
esta generación es la que ha fomentado
concretamente que esto exista pero si
nos gusta el dinero en mano no es un
problema no es un problema real porque
también existe el dinero digital por
cincuenta euros una cuenta de paypal de
unos 500 evidentemente para blanqueo de
dinero de cierto tipo de mafias y cierto
tipo de contrabandistas que estamos
intentando pillar
esto está ahora mismo en auge
concretamente esta investigación se ha
hecho en enero y se prevé un crecimiento
de este tipo de fraudes de
aproximadamente un 84% por mes hasta el
año 2034
porque se puede calcular perfectamente
se puede calcular gracias a los análisis
matemáticos esto es una maravilla la
generación zeta
va a ser la generadora de dos delitos
maravillosos el delito de fraude
de dinero y el delito de fraude de datos
y aquí yo os hago el ejercicio máximo la
única diferencia entre vosotros y
vosotras y yo es que vosotros y vosotras
sabéis cómo os comportáis si yo tengo el
acceso a todos los datos a cómo os
comportáis no hay ninguna diferencia
entre vosotros y yo porque digitalmente
estoy seguro de que nos notáis la
diferencia de si hablo yo o se habla la
persona a la que estáis hablando por
vuestro chat de mensajería instantánea
si tengo los datos de comportamiento de
cada una de las personas de aquí soy esa
persona digitalmente y eso se vende
muchísimo eso se vende muchísimo y es
muy caro es más el mayor tráfico de
datos ilegales no son las fotografías de
un portátil porque estoy seguro de que
muchas de estas personas tienen el
portátil con la cámara tapada no porque
ha salido una persona diciendo que hay
que tapar lo pero estoy seguro de que
estéis 23 horas con el portátil pero sin
embargo cuántos tenéis el móvil en el
bolsillo ahora mismo
los datos que se venden realmente son
conversaciones de whatsapp
conversaciones de telegram investigación
de redes sociales si buscáis en
cualquier red social me quiero morir
vais a encontrar una gran cantidad de
perfiles de personas de entre los 15 y
24 años probablemente estudiantes
a las cuales podéis perfectamente
analizar y simplemente con esos datos
perfectamente podéis haceros pasar por
este tipo de personas podéis saber con
quién hablan en cada momento podéis
saber a quién retuitear ideas políticas
que registro lingüístico están usando
podéis ser esas personas y para qué
sirve esto pues esto sirve para cosas
maravillosas como por ejemplo meterlo en
bancos de datos los bancos de datos se
están muy extendidos y a partir de aquí
y ahora en un futuro van a crecer porque
estamos en la generación de exponer
todos los sentimientos por redes
sociales es poner todo foto cuando se
quieren foto que no sé cuánto voy a si
me cabreo con alguien lo voy a poner y
da igual aunque no lo pongas aunque
vivas en una cueva estoy seguro de que
alguien lo ha hecho por ti de tener un
perfil evidentemente porque nadie va a
vivir en una cueva nadie va a omitir el
móvil nadie va a ver los permisos de las
aplicaciones que se instala
evidentemente me ha bajado un juego por
qué razón no va a tener acceso a mis
contactos que podría salir mal
los datos se acaban en bancos como estos
cada fila de dni vale actualmente 40
euros
cada dato robado de perfil de personas
vale aproximadamente en 352 mil euros
dependiendo de cómo sea para qué sirve
esto por ejemplo para transformar a
todas las personas que yo veo aquí en
prostitutas digitales mediante las
técnicas de hayward porque yo en
determinado momento se me acabará la
imaginación sigo siendo humano
entonces necesitaría tirar de perfiles
de personas para poder hacer cierto tipo
de estafas o comprar un banco de datos
como estos para hacer cierto tipo de
compras en países con la moneda
devaluada que los países con la moneda
devaluada son maravillosos son como
tener un escaparate con un cartel de
abierto 24 horas ven aquí a comprar pero
lo controlan un montón para poder
comprar por ejemplo en brasil cierto
tipo de cosas requiere de identificación
de brasil pues si me compra un banco de
datos de brasil perfectamente puedo
hacer ese tipo de compras sin ningún
tipo de problema
entonces hay que proteger evidentemente
estos datos estos datos son
fundamentales porque si no lo que vamos
a acabar provocando es algo como esta
gráfica esta gráfica se implementa con
los datos generados desde hace bastantes
años hasta el futuro lo que yo preveo
porque vosotros y vosotras habéis venido
aquí a ver el futuro del crimen pero
lamento bastante porque el futuro del
crimen sois vosotros y en vuestra mano
está el cambiar esto que estamos viendo
aquí
por mi parte
y con abnegación voy a seguir aportando
y haciendo aquello que yo quiero que es
proteger aquello que importa desde hoy y
hasta un futuro vuestros datos
muchísimas gracias a todos por haberme
acompañado en este viaje
[Aplausos]
[Música]